remotely we are honored to have Mr
dmitra nataluca a chair of the committee
on economic development of the Ukrainian
Parliament Dr Benjamin mole
microeconomics professor of London
school at Atlanta school of Economics
Mrs Myra Martini research and policy
expert of a Transparency International
and Dr hannes says vobuda president
of the Vienna Institute for
international
economic
studies and Dr timofai Milan milovanov
director of the Kiva School of economics
yes and uh so on behalf of the econ
committee I want to thank uh in
particular our Ukrainian speakers uh Mr
nataluka and Dr Mila milovanova for
meeting us today the purpose of our
meeting is to have an exchange of views
on the economic impact of restrictive
measures against Russia in response to
its brutal aggression against Ukraine
and its people the EU has adopted the
most far-reaching and hard hitting
sanction package ever to date in eight
successive packages aimed at further
intensifying the pressure on Russia to
end the war the most recent of the
eighth sanctioned package was adopted by
the Council on October the 6th indeed
economic and individual sanctions as
well as trade embargers have a
tremendous impact on economic growth and
inflation in Russia in the EU as well as
sanctions have been gradually introduced
over the last eight months a better
understanding of the economic situation
in the expected economic impact in
particular on Russia is of key
importance even though it's not that
easy to do so when we are lacking
relevant data in reliable data on these
indicators assessing the economic impact
of sanctions is also warranted in order
to ensure their effectiveness and
preventing potential circumventions
unicorn's field of competence the war in
Ukraine reinforced the call for Action
in a number of areas that has already
been identified effects and specific
actions concern both the area of
legislation and the scrutiny and
accountability a few important practical
consideration before we we start the
hearing will be held in a format to
enable a dynamic exchange to the extent
that it's possible given that our
speakers are remotely connected but we
will do we will adopt this format so we
will start with the presentations by our
invited speakers of a five minutes each
and then the presentations will be
followed by a first block of four
questions two minutes for each question
and three minutes
for each of the five answers and then a
second block of four questions two
minutes for each question and three
minutes for each answer and then a third
block of four questions again two
minutes for the question and three
minutes for the answers and then if time
allows a additional uh slots will be
allocated on a catch the eye basis now
um I know that uh Mr Demetra netaluka is
as you can imagine connecting in a very
difficult situations and conditions so
he's connecting with a mobile but the
connection is not a very good of course
we can all understand the difficult
situations and we appreciate the fact
that he still agreed in being with us
this this morning uh um probably the the
there will be no image or low quality
image so it's probably we will not have
translations it will not be possible to
do that but uh he I think he will have
his intervention in English so I think
most of us will have no problems in in
following
um so I I don't know if
um yes I see uh Mr nataluca connected
Miss nataluca can you hear us
yes yes can you hear me well yes
perfect thank you very much thank you
for having me thank you for this
opportunity and uh I'm terribly sorry
for uh for the connection for the
absence of the video I would love to see
you all and to uh to exchange uh in in a
more usual way seeing each other but
nevertheless I think that we can we can
proceed quite fine without it and then
have an opportunity to meet each other a
bit later
we hope the same
so yeah okay
um uh thank you very much again
um I I think that what we are witnessing
throughout this nine months has been an
unprecedented
um
of unity uh of of of a compassionate
Behavior absolutely by all of the member
countries and I thank you all
um and the EU in general for
um assisting us so much uh in what
regards not just the sanctions but all
kind of
um support military Financial
humanitarian and else this is very much
appreciated trust me and on behalf of
every Ukrainian I I just wanted to to
say thank you
um the the sanctions uh
Mr nataluca uh we can't uh he hear you
right now
so let's see if we can re-establish the
connection is is there a problem of the
collection I suppose no
no no uh can you hear me again yes yes
yeah okay sorry
yeah so uh the expectations from the
very beginning
um were of course uh incredibly High I
think the IMF and the World Bank were
literally predicting
um the worst recession in in Russian
history
um and um in in March and in April the
the signals were pretty right we have
seen an inflation in Russia peaking up
to 16 in in in in March I think up to 18
more than more than 18 probably in in
April
um and it forced the Russian national
bank
um to increase the rates by up to 20
percent uh trying to characterize the
inflation
um we have introduced a number of
critical critical
measures starting with the financial
um uh with the financial measure of some
ending up with the physical bans on
Technologies Productions raw materials
and so on so forth and I think in my
personal opinion what is going on right
now is that
um we managed to put as much pressure as
possible on Russia but it did
unpredictably
Mr mataluka
we lost you
can you hear me well yes now yes
wow sorry
yeah so uh
I I was saying that Russia did better
than expected by everyone and right now
that we see that there is still a lot of
things to be done
um
in in the in the potential ninth package
that we all expect to be to be enabled
as soon as possible I'm personally
working on the case for example of the
transportation of the Russian oil by the
Greek companies and this is a rather
a rather Paramount aspect of of the
sanctions because it still furnishes and
and pumps the Russian economy and
military war machine
with money we are seeing a great we
didn't see any impact on the export of
of diamonds for instance as a sector in
general they have been using loopholes
to export
those minerals and which is another a
great source of income
um and uh I'm terribly sorry because
when I when I speak from the phone I
cannot eat open any other web like
document I had a I had a document
repaired with all the data but when I
open it the connection is lost I just
tried it to do it so I I have to to keep
everything in in my mind so that is why
you can hear me from time to time but
um sorry
hello can you hear me yes yes we can
hear you
yep
so I I was saying that Russia is still
using loopholes in in specific and then
the uh in in rather
profitable sectors of its economy and
our task will be to try to Target
um Target those sectors and those
loopholes um with with new approaches
um what kind of new approaches might be
used and can how can we put even more
pressure on on Russia using using
um
a new object of of potential sanctions
um right now we are considering uh
considering sanctioning the political
parties in Russia as institutions
so not just some top officials
or some some party officials but parties
in general those parties who have voted
for for this War uh back in in February
is who have enabled it and who have
allowed Putin to introduce uh his his
army on the territory of Ukraine and not
just in 2022 but even even before that
in the situation with Georgia and even
in this situation uh with those Moldova
entrance next year so every time Russia
started the war somewhere as a Russian
Duma uh was sitting there voting
unanimously to allow Putin to introduce
um to introduce the
and the army
Mr nataluka we lost you again
no yes yes sorry what what would that
give us uh we're talking about targeting
uh more than four millions of people in
Russia who are members of those parties
um who are uh basically the backbone of
the regime because in Russia it's pretty
much like in the old old Soviet Union
you cannot succeed in your career if
you're not a party member so um when we
are saying members of the party we are
saying directors and principals of
schools we are saying about directors of
universities we are saying about
um chair people of uh state-owned
Enterprises all those people who secure
uh the the establishment of this regime
once it comes to to the voting process
to elections they are there to make sure
that the parents of the children both
for the right candidate that the
students who protest are ideally
isolated the the employers at the
state-owned Enterprises support the the
specific candidates and so on and so
forth but they haven't been targeted by
the sanctions until today if we manage
to uh to Target specifically the parties
uh I think that this will be a
breakthrough in sanctions in fact that
this might be one of the biggest
sanctions in history not only because of
that but also because members of United
Russia are very famous people starting
from businessmen ending with Sportsmen
artists and so on and so forth who are
well known and who own a lot of assets
outside of Russia so if you take
arshavin for instance he's a football
player who used to play for Arsenal he
owns two Estates worth 26 millions of
pounds on the territory of London and he
is a member of the United Russia now if
for instance United Russia is banned
then we could argue the government of
the UK might seize those assets or at
least arrest them and this is just one
person and imagine how many people there
are outside just like him that is also
an interesting implication of a
potential Visa ban uh because
recognizing United Russia the Communist
Party of Russia Elder prayer and other
parties as organizations that facilitate
terrorism will require those Russians
who are entering the territory of EU to
probably mention that they are members
of such organizations the European
commission has such practice I think
throughout history it has recognized
more than 34 organizations and political
parties as organizations that facilitate
terrorism we're talking about Hamas
we're talking about Hezbollah
uh Mr netaluka
hello
hello yeah now we hear you
sorry
so okay I will I will I will uh sum up
sorry because I don't want to take you
take your time given the connection is
really poor
um to sum up uh I think that we we need
a breakthrough in in the in the next
package of sanctions and the in the
nines beckons of sanctions and
sanctioning sanctioning uh the political
parties uh might wreck a lot of havoc in
Russia and be um that kind of the
Breakthrough because
um if you if you think about it uh it
will Target uh more uh more people that
we managed to Target in the in the
previous eight sanctions and it will
Target the personal uh assets outside of
Russia
um it will Target their ability to
interact with the European banking
financial institutions with chain hotels
with Airlines and so on and so forth and
that will put an incredible pressure on
the on the Russian political regime and
I just wanted to remind reminds you that
there has been a resolution in the
Parliamentary assembly of the Council of
Europe passed just last month which
recognized uh the the responsibility of
Russian political parties for this war
and for its own for the consequences of
this war so
um the take would be to kindly ask the
the partners to support this approach
and to uh to to start considering
recognizing Russian political parties as
organizations that facilitate terrorism
thank you
this
thank you very much uh Mr nataluka I
hope you can stay connected and
and I was thinking if you could send us
the resolution that you just mentioned I
think it would be of interest for us to
to look at it
now let's move on to the next speaker
now I give the floor to Dr Benjamin mole
from macroeconomics professor at the
London School of economics Mr mole you
have the floor for five minutes
good morning
um it's an honor to be here
um can you see my slides
I have some slides
yes yes we can thank you excellent
um so I'm gonna mostly compliment what
uh uh dimitro uh was talking about and
I'm gonna speak about the effect of
sanctions on the EU economy so not on
Russia and importantly not just the fact
of sanctions but also sort of the uh the
the sort of I think it's fair to say
economic war and in particular the
energy war that Russia has been waging
uh in return next slide please
so the main message of my introductory
presentation here is uh basically this
one here on the slide so you know I'm
gonna say the situation is serious the
economic cost of the energy War
um are real uh the one that's
particularly serious is the the gas
cutoff
um and particularly for some countries
I'll come back to this but I think it's
very important to emphasize that
everything we've seen so far in the data
and all the predictions
um are essentially that the EU economy
is uh withstanding and adapting in the
face of this energy war and it's really
I'm gonna sort of argue the price
mechanism doing its job
um so these prices are rising and and
people and firms are adapting in the
face of these Rising prices shortages
and rationing are looking increasingly
unlikely at this point
um as a result we sort of do expect
recessions in some member countries but
really sort of mild ones uh and also
same for the EU economy as a whole in
this presentation I'm going to speak
about
um I'm going to focus on one particular
country that I think is a is a nice case
study but it's sort of representative of
the uh wider EU economy
um the reason I'm gonna speak about that
it's it's my home country and it's a
country I've worked on a lot
um and also uh it was particularly
reliant on Russian energy Imports before
the start of the war for example
um this is sort of a striking number
Russia has supplied 55 so more than half
of all natural gas consumption before
the start of the war next slide please
so it sends in a sense what my
presentation is about is uh this
Photograph here so this is uh I'm sure
you've all seen this North stream one
blowing up
um so that gas is not flowing anymore
and so the question is
um how does an economy adapt uh to this
kind of a shock and what have we seen so
far and what's still gonna come
um next slide
um and what we've seen uh and I'll show
you this in more detail later is
um very substantial drops in gas
consumption uh by both firms and
households
um these are some charts to show you
this this is published each week by the
German Network regulator
um they're doing a very good job in data
provision
um and the the way to read this is on
the left is uh gas consumption by
industry on the right is gas consumption
by households
um these sort of the solid line the the
solid sort of dark gray line with the
dark shaded area around it the gray
shaded area around it is the average of
gas consumption in previous years and
then the orange bars are gas consumption
this year and on the x-axis I should
have said is
um calendar weeks okay so this is sort
of throughout the the year gas
consumption and the reason why it's sort
of a u-shape is because there's a strong
seasonality where in the winter
um people heat more and consume more gas
and so if you look at this uh you'll see
you see already a very large jobs in in
gas consumption larger than a lot of
people thought were possible um before
the war so for example industry
um right now is consuming 25 less gas uh
than the normal overall uh it's sort of
37 percent less than than normal uh and
for households I'm going to come back to
this it's kind of too early to tell uh
because it's only the start of the
heating season now
um but I mean it's it's sort of looking
quite uh encouraging um in particular
you can see there these these last
orange bars there are kind of only half
of uh what the normal bars are part of
this is the warm temperature I'll come
back to this but um you know this is uh
starting to look good
um so large jobs in gas consumption
um next slide please
um if you think back maybe to the
debates at the beginning of the war
where
um uh you know there was a lot of
debates should should we go for a u-wide
energy Embark would say also on gas
um there was always this talk about
um cascading effects um this has not
been mentioned so much recently and so
the worry was always that you'd have
this uh the stop of energy imports from
Russia so in particular gas and then you
take get these sort of domino effects
whereby everything sort of uh breaks
down along the supply chains
um the the graph here is just sort of
what a modern economy looks like this is
sort of a network with many
interconnections and you can sort of see
in principle
um if something breaks down it could be
bad
important Benchmark to keep in mind is
if there was no adaptation of the
economy to the the the the shock or no
substitution and economic parlance
um then essentially what you would
expect is that uh a total production
would drop one for one with gas usage so
even though gas is kind of this small
input in production
um uh it'd be this bottleneck and so
then if gas drops by 25 you'd expect
industrial production to drop by 25 so
for each percentage Point Gas drop there
would be a percentage Point drop in
production and then also GDP
um so what I just wanted to show you
next slide please is
um what what we've seen so far
um and uh the point of this graph here
is this is data up up until the end of
September
um that just was released yesterday
um we've seen only very small drops in
industrial production so it looks
nothing like this no adaptation
Benchmark so the blue line here is
industrial production and that's the
thing to look at and you can see there's
a big drop there um right in the middle
of 2020 that's the covet pandemic but
then after that it's sort of pretty flat
and particular in recent months it's
it's it's pretty flat it's maybe down
one or two percent but it nothing like
uh you know just one for one drop if you
do look in energy intensive sectors you
do see larger jobs and like chemicals
and so on but this is not sort of um
creating these Domino effects along the
supply chain and similarly predictions
of what's going to happen are are very
much in line with this if you look at
the research institutes okay uh next
slide please
um how is this happening I've already
said this
um essentially adaptation or a
substitution along the supply chain
um if you're interested in this there's
a paper on my website called how it can
be done that we wrote in July we also
wrote another paper back in March
um where we collected these kind of
examples
um I'll I'll give you just one because
it's sort of useful
um so bisf the big German chemicals
manufacturer
um they're producing ammonia ammonia is
uh produced gas is used very heavily in
ammonia production and then ammonia is
used to produce fertilizer for example
so what's been happening uh for example
is that BSF rather than producing the
ammonia in their big plant in in Ludwig
South in in Germany is now producing the
ammonia in their other plant in the
United States where gas prices are much
lower and then they're shipping the
ammonia to Germany now that obviously
cost some jobs in Germany in particular
those involved in ammonia production but
it sort of kills these cascading effects
whereby everything else breaks down
um there's other examples I don't have
time to talk about next slide please
now let me turn to households again this
is uh still about gas
I've already said this so for households
I think it's sort of a bit too early to
tell because over the summer
um you know gas consumption is
traditionally very low you can see this
very nicely here in this graph and now
the key thing is going to be what's
going to happen during the the heating
period
um and you know we're not quite there
yet but again if you compare the sort of
orange bars here which is this year's
consumption to the sort of Gray Line
there which is the average of previous
years consumption you can see there's a
very large reduction already part of
this is the the warm weather what you
can you know control for that and the
effect is still there next slide please
um you know just to give you a sense of
what I think is going to be a really
important uh what to focus on or what to
look out for going forward what's going
to be the main determinant of the
economic costs I think it's basically
going to be what's going to you know how
those lines on the previous slide are
going to look like going forward and so
what's going to happen with household
gas demand and uh essentially it's going
to be really critical that these orange
bars stay below the gray line so that
demand will be reduced relative to
previous years
um at the same time you know these these
super high energy prices uh so gas and
other prices are really problematic for
some households especially economically
weaker ones and it's really crucial to
support these households in the face of
these high energy prices the key thing
though is how to do this in a way to uh
not reduce incentives for reducing gas
demand there's sort of plant ways of
doing this which is uh to just cap uh uh
gas prices say like I live in the UK
this is how it's been done here uh from
the point of an economist that's bad
Economic Policy
um what you should do instead is give
people transfers that are not directly
tied to energy consumption and that
preserve incentives for reducing gas
demand uh in Germany where I've been
involved in a debate and a lot of my
colleagues have been as well there's
actually a very promising proposal to do
this by uh they put together sort of an
expert commission I'm happy to talk
about this later in the Q a next slide
um the key thing uh uh the the key other
thing is that if we manage to reduce
demand then this will also have another
important effect which is that prices
are going to fall so uh this is sort of
a doubly good thing
um this is gas prices for example and
you you can see I mean it's already kind
of uh happening right now
um uh so this is gas prices throughout
the year 2022 and they they uh this is
Futures prices I should have said they
skyrocketed a lot um just before the
north stream uh uh one shutdown uh in
the beginning of September end of August
they reached this really high peak there
um at 350 but ever since they've been
coming down
um that's primarily due to demand
reduction basically uh working as
expected next slide please and that's my
final slide so the conclusion is
um you know I think it's very important
to emphasize
um that the EU economy is with sanding
and adapting to a certain extent this is
sort of Economics 101 so the key driver
here is just the price mechanism doing
its job and and resulting in in Falling
demand and people substituting and
adapting uh an important aside
um that I'm happy to talk about in The Q
a as well
um full gas storage is in and off
themselves are not enough and to get
through the winter you really need this
demand reduction
um uh and really you know one reason why
the gas storage is full is the demand
reduction and just looking at the gas
storage and saying uh you know
celebrating when they reach 95 or 100 is
a bit of a distraction that I'm happy to
talk about this later
um again demand reduction by households
will be critical and what you want to do
is alleviate hardships but without
destroying incentives
um I'm gonna stop there I'm
didn't say anything about the effects of
the sanctions on the Russian economy I
did want to say one thing just to
complement dimitro I I think I agreed
with most of what he said
um sometimes you hear people saying the
sanctions aren't working
um I just wanted to say and I'm happy to
talk about this more later I think
they're very much working if they're not
having the effect as some people were
hoping
um uh on the Russian economy then that's
because there's uh holes in the
sanctions and uh that need to be plugged
and uh you know need to be uh you know
the sanctions need to be toughened okay
thank you thank you we are a little bit
over time
um but let's move swiftly to the next
speaker I give the floor to Myra Martini
from Transparency International
hi everyone can you hear me well yes
good thanks thanks a lot for for the
invitation and congratulations also for
for organizing this important discussion
I think I will take us uh in a bit of a
different direction I wanted to talk a
little bit more about individual Target
sanctions and in particular focusing on
some of the challenge
that we see countries are facing to
implement it effectively and the latest
information we have is that the European
Union member states have Frozen
14.5 billion euros in in assets
belonging to oligarchs
and entities connected to them that have
been designated however nineteen percent
of the of the amount Frozen comes from
only six member states Austria Belgium
Germany Luxembourg Ireland and and
France and all together the remaining 21
member states only accounted for 10 of
the frozen assets so of course it's
plausible that certain countries may
have more assets connected to Russians
but nevertheless I think the numbers
call for further analysis to understand
why my what might be behind this
um what we know is that across the
different countries across member states
authorities have been trying to to
identify and Trace assets but really
with their hands tied behind their back
and I want to discuss some of this
challenge that we are seeing
um in in the different work we have been
doing with authorities and and with
civil society in different member states
so historically I think one of the main
issues is that there is a strong
Reliance in Reliance on obliged entities
to implement sanctions so
um Banks but also real estate agents
accountants lawyers so those that have
anti-money Landing obligations and I
think there's this particular
problematic where when we're talking
about the non-financial sector so
designated non-financial business and
professionals because they might not
have a very good understanding of money
laundering risks and also because we
have seen a lot of challenge related to
their effects effective Supervision in
the past and several scandals in the
last years have shown that those obliged
entities were really failing to
understand to to undertake adequate due
diligence enough they don't they didn't
even record
adequate information on their customers
on the beneficial owners and so on and
so forth
and what we know is that oligarchs
kleptocrats corrupt individuals
um and and particularly those who are
likely to be targeted by sanctions do
not own assets on their own name uh so
they use anonymous companies they use
complex structures and they use nominees
sometimes the nominees are even the same
entity that now uh is required to
implement the sanction or the same
profession so there is definitely a
challenge there so freezing and seizing
assets will require investigative work
we cannot take the list of designated
individuals and expect that we can
easily find assets connected to those
so the main challenges we see here is
that one authorities often do not have
the necessary resource and I'm talking
about staff financial and Technical
resource a recent analysis we did show
that in some countries each staff of uh
of financial intelligence unit is
expected to review thousands suspicious
transaction reports on their own in
addition to conducting other tasks and
the Second Challenge is that even the
most reeling authorities may not even
have access to data to carry out
investigation because data is not
available or not collected for example
for most type of assets such as real
estate Yachts Jets and also investment
funds there is no information on the Rio
individuals behind them available to
authorities and for Company ownership
data we know that the existence of
public beneficial ownership registers
across the EU put member states in a
really privileged position because this
information is already helping
authorities also in other countries
to identify potential assets connected
to designated individuals but also steps
should be taken to close remaining
loopholes so improve the quality of the
data ensure direct and unfiltered API
access at least to all relevant
competent authorities which is not the
case at the moment
some in some countries likewise men
authorities cannot even access this
database directly although they already
exists and I and are there
and before concluding I also wanted to
point out to a contradiction in the
sanctions regime which is related to the
prohibition of the provision of trust
service to all Russians so this is in
place from July 2022
trust service providers cannot offer
trust service to Russians all Russians
not only to the designated individuals
the provision also instructs trust
service to Pro to dissolve and return
assets to the owners and if they are
sanctioned in the the assets need to be
frozen but there is a very curious
exemption to this rule which is made for
dual Russian EU citizens so those that
have a European passport or hold a
residence permit in the EU are allowed
to retain their trusts across the block
with everything we know on Golden visas
and passports and the commission's own
recommendations in relation to Russian
Nationals benefiting from these schemes
these exemption raised serious questions
and I think adds here another loophole
to the sanctions regime
and finally I think many of the
challenges we see now can be addressed
in discussions that are ongoing the EU
Parliament at the moment like the
anti-money launching package but also
other proposals we hope this horrible
event will serve as a lesson and that
the systemic issues that have allowed
Russia and putting to gain and sustain
so much power are now uh weak in our
weak in the implementation of sanctions
will be finally addressed so we prevent
also similar abuse in in the future and
that's one final remark I think
connected to what Mr nataluka was
suggesting of of the approach
um of sanctions we have been defending
also from the beginning of of the
invasion that asset tracing efforts
should be expanded to the Russian
political Elite so going Beyond
um oligarchs we believe there is a
really powerful class of officials
working at the Federal Administration in
Russia who are really important to
implement policies in Russia but also to
keep
those that are contrary to the
government in Czech and we feel that and
they also very likely to hold assets
abroad there have been also denounced of
their involvement in corruption and so
on so targeting those could help also
increase pressure inside the country
I'll stop here and happy to go back to
to any of the points I mentioned thank
you in the Q a thank you thank you very
much now I give the floor to Dr uhness
president of the Vienna Institute for
international economic studies
doctors Roberta you have the floor for
five minutes
I'm happy to be back in the parliament
even if only digital I speak on behalf
of the Vienna Institute and the event
Institute is focusing especially on the
eastern part of Europe from the baltics
down to to the Western Balkans
now of course it's difficult to speak
about the effects of sanctions because
the sanctions are always intertwined
with counteractions countersections with
many other economic developments but let
me concentrate on some issues concerning
Russia much has been said it is clear
that our expectation has been
exaggerated we had to change our
forecasts and Russia is doing much
better than was foreseen basically it is
because of internal measures by Russia
itself but also because Russia could
import Goods which were in some sort of
a parallel importation from other
countries when they didn't get the goods
from from Europe or from the United
States but most importantly it's not the
sanctions directly but the withdrawal of
many companies European or Western
companies who did not longer want to be
part of the Russian economy with that
risk role they withdraw also the new
technologies they have been implementing
in the country so that is the major
Point all the other issues are important
psychologically politically but
important is that Russia is deprived as
long as it has this policy from new
technologies and therefore it's very
important to control that these new
technologies are not imported by
somebody else
China turkey will come to to that a bit
later so this is the major issue and of
course it's very clear that the second
most important effect is that uh
qualified young men and women leave the
country therefore whatever we do we
should be very open-minded concerning
also that these people can leave in
Russia because these are the people who
would otherwise contribute to the
technological development of course they
live not only because of political
reason they leave because they don't
want to be part of the war which is also
important so I think whatever we do
against people it is clear that these
people should be not targeted by
sanctions but should be invited to leave
the country and to reduce the economics
for the potential of the country now
coming to Ukraine I just want to mention
that until now Ukraine did very well
much better also than expected in a
positive sense but of course we have to
be careful about any Focus now when
Russia is distracting so much of the
infrastructure and therefore again we
have to
make it very clear that all the every
country which is supporting Russia in
that war including drones from Iran and
so on uh should be targeted also from
other side because it's not only about
sanctioning Russia but it's also to
really get a close focus on those
countries who help Russia to win the war
and here I come to Turkey now we know
that turkey is not following the
sanctions regime turkey is in some way a
place at least where some of the trade
is going uh and is increasing towards
Russia now I know it's a critical issue
because Turkish also helping Ukraine in
some way on the grain Exposition for
example so it is not easy just to Target
Turkey and say you do only a bad job
when it helps us in some way Ukraine but
we should be very careful that at least
not modern technology is exporting via
turkey into into Russia
now as I said The Institute is focusing
especially also in Southeastern Europe
here we find of course a very different
situation what has been mentioned
already in in the second talk I think we
have to look to the poorer part of the
society how they are affected and that
is especially true of course for the
Barkan countries where we have Rising
inflation as in all the countries
especially Rising food prices which is
again affecting people so it's not only
energy as such but the consequences of
high energy on food prices and those
countries and those people who spend
more in percentage of their income and
their expenditure on food of course are
much more affected from the best of
Balkans over those are Hungary Slovakia
so some of the countries have a heavy
burden secondly of course as I said the
energy prices thirdly High interest
rates we have high interest rates in
many of the countries which are
affecting the housing markets and of
course poor people look at the to to
houses and that in addition to higher
housing expenses when we think about
energy and and uh for the electricity
and gas prices
then of course High interest rates also
prevent countries governments and
private companies to get the credits and
for the governments is the problem of
compensating those the poor countries
cannot compensate like some of the rich
encounters inside the European Union
they are poor people for higher prices
so this is an unimported element and
then of course any any
recession in Germany or some other
countries have their effects in smaller
countries who are very much dependent on
export to these countries so let me come
only to one country specifically and
that is Serbia we know that Serbia is
also not following the sanctions uh
until now we don't see much increase in
trade between Serbia and Russia which
could be also a loophole but we have to
be very careful I know the commission
president has been recently in Serbia
but we have to be very careful that
Serbia is not a gate
and the loophole for
transporting special
Goods Technologies and so on uh to to
Russia so I think this is a very
important elements that we have to look
into it uh that these loopholes I spoke
about turkey about Serbia but many other
countries are not used my final remark
of course is going on the energy price
again uh yes um the should be an
incentive for saving energy and it's
working in some way but we should be
very careful that the high energy prices
don't lead to some D industrialization
and your we see already that what the
United States is doing with strong
support for
their industry and if Europe is not very
careful then we have the danger that
some of our good Industries uh moving
out of Europe moving to the USB moving
to Asia so I think in connection with
the sanctions we should look really in
the job losses possibly in Europe
because of an industry moving out of
Europe because of the high prices thank
you very much
thank you thank you very much
now we have a Dr Timo timofey milovanov
I saw he was connected to know if he's
still connected
I know that the secretary that was
testing his connection
foreign
yes I see him
good morning Mr milovanov thank you
thank you very much for being with us
this morning can you hear us
no
okay
all right hello
so just press once on the speak button
please
sir just once please
okay can you hear me now yes yes we can
hear you
good thank you
you know yeah I just got connected so I
I didn't hear the prompt
um
I I how how long can I speak for or
should I speak for oh you have five
minutes but if you you know you need a
couple of minutes more yeah thank you
really appreciate uh your being with us
this morning thank you
all right so my job is to describe the
situation with the economy in Ukraine
the
and I'm happy to comment on other
economic related issues
um
please correct me if I'm wrong about uh
you know or if I deviate in terms of the
focus and you want something else
on the economy in sometime in the summer
um
we have been getting essentially pretty
bullish reports that the economy has
adopted as a result of the war of course
we're going to lose about 30 to 40
percent of
GDP relative to the previous year but
then we thought that the situation in
Ukraine is coming to some kind of
steady state however the most recent
in the most recent
attacks on the energy infrastructure
have affected our ability to provide
electricity and more recently water and
waste management
to the largest cities
as a result the government
electricity regulator has imposed
sufficient restrictions on the
electricity consumption included by the
industry multiple companies have been
reduced their quarters by 30 or more
that means that will be further
reductions in in the ability to produce
goods and
GDP is likely to fall further
while there is no precise estimate of
forecast yet
uh we can see some of this reflected in
the budget which has been just passed by
the parliament of Ukraine there's a
revised forecast there was an optimistic
growth in the fear of several percent uh
of four percent grows in the first
forecast now they revised it down to one
point uh 1.5 uh further they have uh
uh revised more optimistic inflation
which means basically that the economy
production will be suffering
um the
um the damages there is no precise
assessment of the recent infrastructure
damages but they probably run in tens of
billions of dollars
and the situation is
a little bit more difficult than saying
than tends to be reflected in the media
for example in Kiev as of yesterday some
of apartments and that's typical had uh
only several hours of electricity a day
so that that's gonna that's gonna
negatively affect the economy but
fundamentally the economy during the war
the wartime economy in Ukraine is very
simple you don't you don't have any
investment
uh the consumption
um the consumption the private
consumption has gone down significantly
maybe times maybe it was one-third of
what it was before the War uh and the
government expenditures on social
support and infrastructure support and
on Military have increased
this means that a substantive part of
GDP actually about 20 of GDP in the next
year is going to be the military
expenditures
the government faces a 36 38 billion
dollars budget deficit but I think this
number is optimistic we probably will be
facing by the time by the mid of the
next year the annual budget deficit of
uh maybe 50 billion dollars that's uh
keeps School of Economics assessment but
that disagrees with the assessment with
the current forecast of the of the of
the government so the government is
asking for about three billion dollars
support annually but I think our numbers
are more consistent with what the IMF is
putting forward
um is about five uh billion dollars a
month that's what will be the forecasted
need according to our estimation because
we run a little bit more pessimistic
scenarios on infrastructure damages we
think Russia will continue to Target uh
critical infrastructure in Ukraine the
current damage assessment overall direct
damages are at 127 billion dollars this
is the latest keep School of Economics
estimate of September they do not
include the October energy assessments
uh critical infrastructure damages those
are likely to stay classified and
probably won't be released for a while
but I think again the tens of billions
of of dollars and I think I'm out of
time thank you
thank you thank you very very much uh
now of course as we open the floor for
questions if maps have
additional questions to uh Mr milovanov
as well as to the other speakers we will
have the time to go in further details
so let's get started with the first
round
um we start with the ludek neither Meyer
for EPP
uh thank you thank you madam chair I
have three uh questions to our panelists
the first concerns the data on Germany
as was presented by August from LSI uh
I've under to which extent you think
that there is the risk that after the
governments will Implement different
kind of support supportive protective
measures price caps that the consumption
will not continue to to to be lower the
second question August from Transparency
International talk about the freezing of
private assets and I guess there is not
just one challenge that we talk about so
that means right identification but
there is also Second Challenge and this
is how to use this assets so I wonder if
the speaker has any opinion and last to
probably I'll guess sobera from from
Vienna
I wonder how you put into the picture
of the impact on the sanction the the
role of the third countries as you said
on one hand there is the risk that they
will undermine our let's say especially
Technologic and Military embargo on the
other hand
it's important that Russia keep
exporting some some Goods to poor
countries in order to allow them to have
access to fertilizers or or the food but
still I guess we need to somehow control
the financial Avenues of the Russian
state so so just to make it more simple
how you think that we should the our
policy should be oriented towards the
third countries as concerned embargo
thank you
thank you very much now
Juanes Fernandez for the snd group so we
are collecting uh four questions in a
first block and then we have a first
round of answers
thank you very much Madam chair I'll be
speaking Spanish if that's okay
well first of all I'd like to send a
message of solidarity to Professor Milo
panov milovanov from the European
Parliament is standing by
the chairman in corrupt interrupts from
the platform you can switch the language
and have a translation you know because
sometimes people that are not used to
our platform they don't know so please
make sure that you you can have a
translation in
in English or in other languages thank
you yeah I'm sorry I can't speak in
English but no I think if if uh if
nobody complains or saying anything I
think you can go ahead okay
see
one of us
well first of all
I would like to
um
salute Mr and Dr milavanov the European
Parliament has stood by Ukraine and will
continue standing next to uh Ukraine and
I'd also like to greet Dr swabara Who
also chaired my parliamentary group I
have two questions
the first one is more for Myra martini
it's on individual sanctions and whether
they have worked or not on referring to
the individual sanctions that have gone
through over the last few months and the
fact that some European countries
haven't been incorporating and thinking
of Switzerland in particular the country
has frozen 6 billion Euro
uh in assets but we were talking about a
lot more in Switzerland when it comes to
Russian assets so we feel that this is a
loophole in the sanctions that maybe we
need to revise and I'd appreciate your
opinion on them now my second question
is for Dr Benjamin mole from the LSC you
said that we need to have these price
signals in order to make sure that we
focus on the incentives when it comes to
consumption of gas so and we also need
to help more vulnerable households but
the situation is so critical that
there's a lot of political pressure to
help not only more vulnerable households
but to the industrial Fabric and the
whole of society there's huge pressure
and so in the Sunday universities are
talking about price signals and having
protection systems for the most
vulnerable or from the most humble
background so that is quite easy to
handle politically but I'd like to know
whether you have any ideas on how we
could Implement these kind of measures
thank you thank you very much uh
Georgia's kids us for being you
thank you very much um
is there any assessment of member states
in the sense
which are effective in
imposing sanctions
and which states avoid the
responsibilities
for instance my country Greece is very
slow in decreasing its dependency on
Russian
gas natural gas
and according to what I read in the
international press 50 percent of the
Russian oil
is transported by Greek vessels
since the Greek Merchant Fleet is huge
so because
one has to evaluate the performance of
its members that member state in order
to reach
[Music]
a common approach eventually and the
other thing is about the golden Visa
golden visas are very applied
in a large scale in Greece as well so do
you have any
any additional information on how they
use Russian oligarchs in
the Putin system in general could use
Golden visas to avoid the sanctions
thank you very much
thank you very much and let's talk to
soon for the greens
thank you so much let me first also
Express to Mr natalugal my the support
and sympathy on behalf of the greens in
the European Parliament and thank him
particularly for being here with us and
also to the other speakers
my question goes
um a bit following what juanas Fernandez
said on the the problem that we have
with the sanction are very much linked
also to the loopholes that we have in
our EU legislation this has been
appointed by the representation of
Transparency International and also with
the interesting report they they just
published and one of the things that is
interesting for this Parliament
um now is actually how to fix some of
those loopholes in our IML framework now
that we are in the middle of the of the
revision of the directive and the
regulation so I would like to ask our
speakers and particularly the
representative of Transparency
International what are your views on
what the EU should change to address
those loopholes that would indeed
effectively allowed to track better
Russian assets covered by by sanctions
and particularly I would like to know uh
your opinion on the possibility for
instance of setting up an asset registry
at your level
um uh firstly secondly how do you think
we should strengthen the beneficial
ownership of companies which I think is
at the core of the problems we are
having
and finally how to address the issue of
of non-compliance by professional uh
professional enablers which I think is
another big loophole that we have in our
IML legislation I would like to know
your opinion about those three things
thank you
okay so
um we have now a round of our answers
um I think most of the questions were to
all of the speakers so we'll just go
through them in the meantime Mr nataluca
had to uh disconnect uh but the other
speakers can answer these questions so
let's start from Dr Mull
okay
um yeah two very good questions so I'm
gonna answer jointly uh Mr neither Myers
and Mr Fernandez's question because
they're very related so Mr niedermeier's
question was I'd shown these charts uh
of gas demand dropping a lot
um uh in in Germany uh and the question
was now if we if governments Implement
these supportive measures sort of gas
price caps and so on do I expect uh this
demand reduction to be to be less or
disappear and which could then lead to
shortages I guess so the the the ants
and then Mr Fernandez's question was
about industry
um the the answer to Mr Kneaders Meyer's
question is
um what's important is that you know if
the governments were indeed to implement
sort of gas price cabs
um then I would indeed be worried but
the important thing is that at least in
the case of Germany
um post policy and what they're most
likely going to adopt is not actually a
gas price cap it's a little bit
confusing because in the in the media
and the the words also the politicians
use they always say gas price break or
gas price in German but the commission's
proposal is actually nothing like that
instead it's what economists call a a
lump sum transfer so basically people
get a transfer that's linked to their an
estimate of their gas consumption which
is based on their last year's energy
consumption so in particular if you save
a lot of gas so you reduce your gas
consumption a lot you still get to keep
that transfer which is very different
from a price cap or a subsidy where if
you reduce your gas consumption you lose
uh uh the the money so here instead with
the proposal of the commission for X for
every extra kilowatt hour of gas a
household saves they saved the entire
market price
which is very high and not just the sort
of uh cap price so and this is really
the the the sort of neat thing about
this commission's proposed so hopefully
the German government will adopt this uh
and then uh this is much better policy
than the price Gap the worry that I have
there is uh well twofold so first of all
in the case of Germany the challenge is
communicating this correctly so if all
people uh and firms think this is indeed
a price cap even though it's not then I
guess it's it's sort of going to
backfire and not going to have the
intended effect and and to incentivize
so it's really important the politicians
communicate this directly and so far
they're not doing that great a job so
there's lots of room for improvement
um the second thing is uh similar
policies in other countries so in other
countries there are indeed a lot of
countries that are actually just
adopting or look like they're going to
adopt these sort of Brute Force price
caps and then I I'd be worried about uh
the desired effect of uh on incentives
and demand reduction and then finally
turning to Industry so this was Mr
Fernandez's question
um so what's what they've proposed in
Germany um is basically to adopt a very
similar model for firms where basically
also firms get a transfer that's uh
based on their previous year's energy
consumption and so just to help with the
the gas but so if you use more in the
past you get more money but it's in such
a way that uh uh uh you know the
incentives for reducing gas demand are
are still preserved so I think basically
the same logic that you know I've
explained for households you can use for
industry and that's good policy and that
should help with also the concerns about
sort of de-industrialization that Mr
swoboda raised
I'm going to stop there
thank you thank you very much now I give
the flower to maida martini
thank you yeah very interesting
questions thanks a lot let me go through
them so the first question on how to use
the assets that uh are now being frozen
this is this is key because under a
sanctions regime you cannot confiscate
assets right so that's why we have been
saying that we need real accountability
so we need to go beyond uh the sanctions
to really investigate the origin of of
the funds that were used to purchase the
assets and go through the process to
confiscate and to do this in in a timely
manner in a time that brings
accountability uh as quick as possible
it's really important that member states
have the legal tools to do that so
non-conviction based firefighter or
unexplained wealth orders or even uh
sanctions Invasion as a crime because
this would allow authorities to do
investigations and pursue accountability
and against their assets not necessarily
against the individual which then has a
lower uh burden of proof and
um a bit easier to achieve wires still
respecting the process and rule of law
and so on we know that there are
discussions currently uh with the
directive that has been proposed that
would uh improve
um non-conviction based firefighter
across the union and I think this is
really really important if we want to
talk about
being able to confiscate the assets and
then use
um uh the funds uh the other point was
around cooperation by different
countries in the implementation of
sanctions Switzerland was mentioned but
I think it's really important to
highlight there have several other
countries are quite resistant in
implementing sanctions and could
actually be supporting those trying to
evade sanctions we have seen recently
news about Hong Kong uh in a yacht that
was was there there have been a lot on
the UAE and the role of Dubai for
example in supporting sanctions Invasion
potentially so I think it's really
important here that the European Union
try to
um
coordinate with Partners on proactively
exchanging information we know
transnational case very often you need
information that is elsewhere to even be
able to implement sanctions on your own
country so I think would be very useful
to try to do more in a proactive manner
rather than just reacting to findings of
specific investigations there is this
transatlantic task force repo that has
been created we have been pushing for
broadening the the Mandate of this task
force but also broadening uh
participation in Switzerland I think
it's a crucial country that should be
part of of those efforts and on the
assessment of the implementation of
sanctions and what countries have been
doing
is something else so that uh the
European Union could do more in
requesting countries to publish more
information currently we don't have a
systematic way uh uh countries don't
publish information regularly so some
countries like France will publish a
list of Frozen uh properties for example
but this is not information that is
systematically published by all
countries which makes it very difficult
for us to assess what has been done and
what has not been done
uh on Garden visas
um again we are Transparency
International have been highlighting uh
the risks posed by Golden visas
particularly because there is more than
enough evidence that countries are not
doing the needed checks uh before
granting citizenship or resident uh to
applicants Russians have been
um among those uh that have in in many
countries applied for uh for Golden
visas we know through leaks that many of
them have with a shady background and
Shady source of fun have been awarded
golden visas and now there is a debate
on what needs to be done to other revoke
uh the golden visitor has been awarded
or at least outed past
um
past Awards I think how it could be used
here in theory uh when engaging with an
obliged entity for example they should
disclose all their nationalities but in
practice what we see and I have found
myself in beneficial ownership registers
case where Russians have been reporting
a different citizenship than the Russian
one thanks to Godin Visa which makes the
process for identifying a potential
assets a bit longer because it's not
that's that straightforward so it
certainly makes easier for them to open
bank accounts or to engage with obliged
entities across Europe without raising
as much res red flag as they would
otherwise and finally
on the the question made by the greens
on on the loopholes and there were
several questions there so let me start
with the asset register the report we
just published a couple of months ago
ago called up to the task one of the
things we highlighted is how in spite of
countries across Europe having set up
beneficial ownership registers it's
still possible
to purchase assets remaining Anonymous
that's because I can set up a company in
another country that doesn't have a
beneficial ownership register and come
to a European country and invest in that
country so purchase either property or a
luxury good and then I don't need to
register in the bureau register that's
not the case everywhere but in most
countries so there is a significant
loophole there that is very easy to
address you should simply require that
every single company
investing in a member states needs to
fulfill the same requirements of a
domestic company so needs to disclose
their beneficial owners so if they open
a bank account if they purchase a
property if they purchase another type
of asset they should be required to
disclose their beneficial owner this
would bring us very close to an asset
register what we call a global asset
register because then we would have
information and beneficial ownership
information of the real owners of all
types of assets in that specific Country
Now an asset registered to be really
effective should be connected no so
ideally authorities should be able to
easily connect those different data sets
and use that for investigation now on
measures to instruct strength and
current to strengthen vo registers it's
a long list so I'll try to prioritize
here
um I think number one is the definition
that is currently being used
the the directive talks about the 25
threshold of ownership interest what we
have seen in in different countries is
that
um this threshold is really problematic
depending on the types of
um of legal entities we are talking
about if you're talking about investment
funds we're not going to know whose
interest is there if we apply directly
to this threshold so there needs to be a
better understanding of the risks and we
need to look to lower this threshold
depending on the type of legal entity we
are talking about the second thing is
the coverage so there are some types of
legal entities that fall outside of the
scope and that that's the ones that are
being abused so we saw for example in
Ireland a peak in the number of Irish
limited Partnerships that have been
registered since the beneficial
ownership started to to to be in place
because this type of company is not
under the the the current rules to
declare beneficial owners so covering
those loopholes are really really
important and then finally I think has
to do with verification of the data we
need to resource in power and give the
mandate to registry authorities to
independently check the information that
is in the register so it's not so easy
for for those to put nominees or proxies
uh instead of declaring the real
beneficial owner and finally sorry I
know it's taking long on the
non-compliance by professional enablers
a crucial measure here is to improve
supervision of non-professional enablers
we know that in many countries
um supervision is currently left to
professional associations it's also
sometimes you have more than one body in
the country responsible for supervising
sometimes
more than 10 of them for supervising one
single type of of profession I think we
need to have more coherence in this
approach and we need to have more
control by a government agency that that
can check if uh
their professionals and business are
fulfilling their requirements are
reporting understand the risks and so on
and so forth so making sure that
supervision is not left to the the
professional bodies themselves
thank you thank you very much we are a
little bit over time let's see if we can
recover
uh Dr zabuda
to be very short on the question of Mr
nidamma which is a very important one I
just would say yes we have to allow
economic and trade by Russia if it helps
to solve a very urgent issue which is
poverty and famine and if it does not
damage to Ukraine so it's a there's no
you know specific rule where you can say
yes or no but I think it's always a
politically evaluation and therefore we
should do that on technology it's
different and I think it's not so much
the export which is interesting but the
import to Russia we should have control
what we need is of course more more
allies in our activities worldwide and
if we would prevent the fight against
poverty and famine
by preventing
export of fertilizers and grain then we
will not win allies in our fight against
the Russian aggression so this is the
one point uh very briefly only to the to
the price cap for industry and for for
consumers I fully agree with Mr Maul we
have to have bills you have to have
support necessary support for consumers
in industry but also incentives to save
energy if you don't do that it can be
very expensive we see that the situation
in Hungary is specifically critically on
the collect side because there is an
overuse of just price cap and financing
so by the budget and the last point on
the gold Visa it's my personal opinion
because we had the debate for many years
already when I was still a member of the
parliament the golden visas are very
often used for money laundering even if
not together with the sanctions so we
should have much much more transparency
on this issue and be rather very
restrictive on the golden visas but
that's my personal opinion thank you
thank you very much now I give the floor
to Mr Milan milovanov I hear that he he
couldn't hear Mrs Fernandez question but
his questions were mostly directed to Mr
mole and Mrs Martini so I I think
there's no problem Mr milovanov
thank you very much I appreciate the
opportunity to speak actually I want to
follow up on the
Ukrainian position or the LaSalle
position with respect to sanctions on
Russia and with respect to the
consumption of energy
in Europe I think incentives are
critical because Russia is using
the dependence the high consumption to
be able to create Leverage
and so
economic incentives to
gradually but meaningfully reduce
consumption
um are important to make Europe
independent of uh Russian leverage in
the future
um so this price caps are worrisome for
us and for me personally as an economist
because it does create certain perverse
incorrect incentives on Golden visas uh
you know I can I know the information
from this side of the world and they
indeed often are considered to be a
mechanism for again I also will say this
is my personal opinion but from people
from talking to some intelligence that
used to to bring money for uh money
laundering and on sanctions and on
effects in particular on global South
um
of
I think we should not underestimate how
Russia interacts and campaigns and
Global South and makes arguments the
sanctions are counterproductive which is
completely incorrect because
um and is there are of course a lot of
specific issues and uh hiccups with
sanctions and if the sanctions uh uh
create
humanitarian issues for other countries
they have to be addressed but at the
same time it's critical to continue to
deprive Russia from funding from the
rest of the world and
ban critical Imports for them that they
um that they use for uh for for defense
and for well for military because Russia
is now a an authoritarian regime with an
aggressive military power and the
purpose of sanctions is continued to
create uh pressure on Russia to deny
Russia from the ability to run
aggressive military regime to the extent
it is possible thank you
thank you very
much I give the floor to Antonio Rinaldi
ID
RIS
thank you very much Madam chair I'd like
to put a question to Dr Benjamin Moore
from the lse this is the question do you
not think that the European commission
should have taken a preventive approach
and carried out an impact assessment on
The Economic Consequences on EU
countries I'm raising this problem
because implementing the packages of
sanctions haven't respected the
principal of fair they're not
symmetrical I'll give you a
straightforward example the fourth set
of sanctions dating back to April
a cow accounts for certain exceptions
for certain Goods 300 Euro for fashion
items 750 for electronic appliances for
electronic appliances a thousand Euro
for musical instruments 1500 but 50 000
Euro for vehicles so these are
manufacturer's prices so then we're
talking about twice as much when there's
for retail prices because of transport
and other things along the supply chain
50
000 for a vehicle I mean
so that basically means no sanctions
when it comes to vehicles and get when
it comes to Fashion it's a different
situation so my question is
uh there was a real lack of an impact
assessment so we have these random
numbers without any criteria
underpinning them that was my first
question the second one is for Mr svor
Buddha from the Vienna Institute for
international economic studies
Mr swoboda do you not think that
by using crypto assets Russia is evading
these sanctions don't you think that
when's it crypto that the chains in the
the links in the chain are too long
thank you left
thank you very much Madam chair
I would like to thank all the speakers
for their presentations and further
contributions to today's debate
my first question
is for Dr mole Mrs martini and our
former colleague Dr schwabada
and this is for the second part of the
title of the debate in other words what
is the impact of the eight sets of EU
sanctions on the EU economies or the EU
economy in the member states economies
I felt that this part of the title
wasn't really covered by the initial
presentations so the focus wasn't really
on that uh sanctions are a double-edged
knife there will be a negative impact
not only on the Invader Putin but also
will have an impact on the EU economies
given the forecasts for 2023 in other
words that we have the the threat of
recession looming and the increase in
disparities given that I'd like to know
what your assessment is of the impact of
these sanctions on the EU the EU economy
and the member states
we also have indications
that inequalities are increasing
my second question
refers to
evaluating or assessing to what extent
EU member states are Towing the line are
respecting the sanctions and this ties
in with what Mr kirto said
there was a reference to Greek ship
owners and the fact that they're
transporting Russian oil
the Russian petrol oil so
I would like to know what measures the
speakers think should be adopted in
order to better tackle this problem
now another question you look at
economic indicators and that's what you
measure but are you also interested or
concerned with the issue of how long
these sanctions have to go on
there's the issue of a ceasefire
diplomacy talks and a restoration of
Peace so that we can help Ukraine with
their reconstruction but also protect
our economies from a deadly increase in
debts and the Advent of recession and
more social inequalities you look at
economic models are these factors that
you're including thank you
thank you very much now I give the floor
to Paul Tang for snd
yeah I would like to thank the speakers
for their contributions for this very
important topic
um we've tried to make the effects
sanctions
work effectively
um I will focus on the discussions that
we also have in European Parliament uh
concerning uh beneficial owners so I
assume that my questions are mainly
addressed to miss Marini but if other
speakers want to contribute to that I'm
happy to hear that
because the problem is that
ownership can be hidden behind the
corporate fail in The Limited
Partnerships in Ireland is one of these
examples but trusts uh can also be one
of those tools
um that was a bit saying that if we
would un unfill the corporate and fill
the corporate structure and see the
beneficial owner we would have a global
asset register and I find a bit bustling
because
I don't think we
register ownership even from corporate
side on many on different types of
assets including for example
um
diamonds or works of art or crypto
assets
if you want to have a global asset
register shouldn't they be include this
type of assets be included in the
register
so we register the ownership of uh like
I said diamonds and workers of art or
crypto assets and you also see a shift
towards it as a way to escape the
sanctions is there a reaction
more generally more broadly do you see
attempts to avoid sanctions to areas
which are unregulated at this stage
thank you Paul now I give the floor to
engineer glue for renew group
s
thank you I'd also like to thank the
speakers for their views I'd like to
concentrate on the sanctions it's clear
that we want to provide financial and
Military Support to Ukraine
and also
we're focusing on a war that's been
going on since 2014 uh through the
escalation by Putin and we're looking at
the costs on both sides and we've heard
from the speakers that the impression
could be created that sanctions uh are
not uh achieving their objective and I
think we need a better Communications
strategy from research from the
parliament making the clear which
sanctions are working and how and what
the economic impact is
and that we need to continue to extend
the sanctions because
I don't think that Putin is going to
stop the war anytime soon and so I think
the question would be to the researchers
that we have here
what do you think of the notification
from Morgan Stanley that India will be
more than doubling its uh G
DP and whether or not there would be a
possibility for for Russia to circumvent
the sanctions for going through India
and then the question would be who would
be participating in the sanctions
against Russia and if the figures that
we've got this morning from Morgan
Stanley are correct this is something we
really have to look into thank you
thank you very much now I give the floor
to Margarita Marquez for the snd group
thank you chair let me speak my native
Portuguese
like my colleagues
let me thank all panelists
we heard about all the different
elements
and that's allowed for a lot of insight
into
the impact
on the ground in Ukraine but also in the
EU and in third countries
I think this has been a very interesting
debate and I have several questions
three to be exact
the first is for Mr Neta Luca
who gave us an analysis of the
relationship between the EU and Russia
and I have a specific question
what about dialogue
and how do we reach out to Russian Civil
Society
can we establish a dialogue with those
who are critical of the political and
Military leadership in Russia at the
present time
second question
my second question might be answered by
Mr or Dr Benjamin mole
he said that there has been an impact
in industrial production a drop it could
lead to economic Fallout recession
joblessness
and Mr swabader similarly spoke about
the risk of relocation
companies might be struggling in Europe
as a result they may turn their
attention to third countries to produce
their instead and of course
this affects employment levels so my
question
how do we deal with the economic and
social Fallout of sanctions in the EU
because this social and economic impact
needs to be responded to we need to come
up with the right
measures to cushion that blow
if we don't do that
then we lose the trust and confidence of
citizens
in the strategy we're pursuing as the EU
as we support Ukraine
so this boils down to the following
how do we cushion the blow
the social economic and political blow
because we can't fail to cushion that uh
economic and social blow
then there's also the threat of
anti-democratic values those who aren't
in line with EU values the extreme right
they want to make the most of this
current set of circumstances they want
to make the most of it to boost
themselves and
uh I'll stop there thank you very much
thank you very much
we have our round of answers and as I
mentioned earlier uh Mr nataluca had to
leave earlier and so he's not connected
anymore but I will give the floor to Dr
Mall
great thank you
um so yeah there were if I kept track
questions by Mr Rinaldi Mr Papa di mulis
uh I'm gonna say something about what Mr
rogloo said and Miss Marcus
um so Mr Rinaldi your question I
couldn't quite catch everything because
of the simultaneous translation
um if I understood correctly the
question was about
um should there have been an impact
assessment of the sanctions in
particular I think you were talking
about the uh sanctions on exports of the
European Union to Russia's Russian
Imports and you know why the different
restrictions where they came from
um
I'm not quite sure how how these
particular numbers were reached I do
think um there were
um I mean at a broader level plenty of
um assessments maybe not by the European
uh commission or European Union
um but I mean by independent research
organizations and so on so
um I mean my sense was that there was
plenty of Assessments and uh of of of
these sanctions before they were
implemented and this sort of also is a
segue into the second question by Mr
Papa dimulis who had asked what our
sanctions are sometimes a bit of a
two-edged sword and I guess he was
particularly referring to the eighth
sanctions package which I think then he
had in mind the oil price cap I'm
assuming
um I want to say one thing there and I
guess this is also related to Mr
Rinaldi's question
um you know sometimes so so it is
obviously true that sanctions do not
only have an effect on the Russian
economy but also on the European economy
this is very much true
um so in that sense it is a two-edged
sword but sometimes you hear these
stories or descriptions in the media or
people who make these statements that
sanctions uh hit ourselves harder than
the Russian economy
um I I just want to be clear that in
terms of the sanctions I've seen
implemented so far I think this is very
far from reality for any of these
sanctions
um any estimates of the effects of these
sanctions and again there have been Lots
of impact assessments are that the
effects on the Russian economy are much
much uh stronger than on the European
economies I think a good rule of thumb
is sort of something like an order of
magnitude worse like a factor of five
for ten where so you know if you think
GDP in Germany is going to drop by one
percent uh because of the oil prices
encapsate and you think that the effect
on Russia will be
um five percent or something so
um you know I I just want to sort of
push back and I mean I'm not sure this
is what you had in mind but if if anyone
has in mind this idea that sanctions set
ourselves harder than uh I think that's
wrong Mr eroglu also already said some
of these things I think the important
thing is that we need to communicate
exactly what each set of sanctions is
doing so I very much just wanted to
agree with Mr arugula's point there and
what we expect these effects to be and
we do need to be careful to be realistic
not to create unrealistic expectations
um uh so so yeah that's that's important
um Mr roglo had also said something
about
um this Morgan Stanley report
um According to which then the Indian
economy is growing a lot and so then
Russia may be able to sell a lot of
energy to to India instead
um so I think there's definitely some
truth to that so you know I was talking
about adaptation and substitution
um that we see by European firms and
households
um I think the important thing to
realize that is it is true that this
sort of adaptation and substitution Cuts
both ways in the same way that the
um you know German or european economy
is adapting also the Russian economies
adapting and yeah of course they're
going to sell their their their oil um
elsewhere but again I I do think that's
still gonna be the case that our
sanctions are are going to hit a demo a
lot harder than they're going to hit us
and then the second thing is yeah we
need to then think about ways ways to
prevent that and I think for example
this uh ban on insurance is a promising
start that's obviously still some holes
in this uh but but you know this is a
good start finally um on Mrs Marcus's
Point
um yeah I I think I just wanted to
broadly agree with most of the things
that were said
um yes it's 100 extremely important to
make sure that the energy War doesn't
create in a sort of uh in the social
fabric falling apart and problems with
industry how how do we do this I think
I've sort of already talked about this
so the key is to straddle this sort of
balance between providing relief to both
households and Industry and at the same
time preserving incentives for uh for uh
saving energy again I I would highly
encourage everyone to read this proposal
of the German gas commission which is
really a very good uh proposal from the
point of view of you know Economic
Policy I mean I think you know maybe can
serve as a model for other countries and
hopefully the the Germans will actually
um adopt that
um you know apart from that also uh yeah
I think if if we need to we we have a a
social market economy we have these
social safety nets
um and so we need to use them
um and and I mean I would say in the
case of Germany for example yeah yeah
I'm I'm sorry if you can conclude
because we I'm afraid we we don't have
that may I ask you you if you can share
with us this proposal from the German
gas Commission because I didn't know
about it I think it would be interesting
to to take a look uh we would be happy
if you can share the document on the
impact assessment just as a reminder for
the colleagues at the beginning of the
war we shared a lot of it's true there
were many think tanks or economies that
were publishing papers and articles
about the assessment of the of the
sanctions and our former colleague Luis
garlicano shared a lot of them and back
then and and I just recalled that if we
had to wait for a formal assessment by
the commission it would have taken
months and normally when we have when
you have a war you want to reply in a
shorter span of time also because if we
had to take seven eight months to
respond to the war back then we wouldn't
be talking about Ukraine today because
we wouldn't have Ukraine anymore by now
so I give the floor to a maida martini
responding to Mr Tank's questions I
would definitely agree that trusts are
still a very important loophole there is
an opportunity now to try to address and
increase transparency of trust and other
legal Arrangements the financial action
task force is currently reviewing the
global standards which means we can try
to to to have stricter measures
including mandatory registration of
trust that's what we have been calling
for so that we ensure that other
countries outside of the EU also
Implement stronger measures that then
would impact for example the information
that is available on assets owned by
Foreign trusts across the EU on the
global asset register I fully agree I
think what I meant before is some of the
measures that are currently being
discussed as part of the the sixth
directive would bring us closer to a
global asset register but I fully agree
that fully fund I said this the register
would need to include all types of
assets
including diamonds arts and crypto
assets and we need to regulate those in
countries that are where they're still
not regulated and importantly this needs
to be at the beneficial ownership level
so we want to know a natural person's uh
holding those assets those at the end of
the chain and in control and I would add
here just very briefly that investment
funds so private equity and hedge funds
are not new from an unregulated Market
but I think we also need to pay closer
attention to those because the current
rules we have are not sufficient to have
a good understanding of who the end
investors are so who are the individuals
that are putting money pulling money in
those funds that are then used to
on assets across uh the European Union
so pay more attention to that and making
sure that we close existing loopholes uh
so that we can know also how those
assets are potentially being used to to
land their money thank you
thank you very much now I give the floor
to doctors bobuda
the first question by Mr Ronaldo for me
is about the cryptocurrency and the
crypto assets I think this is the
biggest issue we have on the financial
and monetary markets that uh more and
more there is evading there are criminal
gangs and their criminal countries who
try to to use cryptocurrencies for doing
the bad job and if we allow that
I'm not an expert how to prevent it but
if that allow that then we can forget
about sanctions because everything will
be done on the cryptocurrencies
uh yes well I try to to speak about the
economic impacts
um especially on the inequality
inflation is biting into the purse into
the money assets of especially of the
poor people with especially the food
prices and so on so what is important is
of course to help financially so social
expenditure but we have to get the
inflation done because inflation is also
biting into our competitiveness in
vis-a-vis to other countries and other
regions from the US to to Asia on your
question about how the sanctions can go
on the difficulty is that if we would
and you mentioned you know any kind of
you know ceasefire whatever
any solution with the Putin regime
brings the danger and I understand the
fear of the ukrainians that after some
break he will start again
so we cannot say okay we you stop the
war and we lift the sanctions because
that is too easy so we have to think
about sanctions going on for a longer
time
what is important just to say about the
sanctions and the effects on Europe in
Europe of course inflation is the big
issue but in in Russia it's the
technologically setback the backward
Trend in Russia which gives a very hard
time for the Russian economy at least in
the medium and long term if we prevent
the Technologies uh you know passing by
the sanctions and and taking another way
so that's the important issue uh to keep
sanctions as long as the Putin regime is
existing and there's not there's no
change in the whole attitude I don't
speak about the regime change about the
attitude towards the neighborhoods and
thoughts of peace and stability in
Europe and that gives also me some
question to what uh mother Marcus said
um we have to reach to the Civil Society
therefore with the sanctions on persons
we have to very be very careful we have
to win over some of the second third
level
Elite who is more and more seeing that
Putin is leading them in in a totally
wrong and destructive way we have to
have allies in Russia which can bring
about the change in the political
attitude therefore yes very much against
for the sanctions and the assets control
and whatever but I'm apparently thinking
Europe especially Europe America is not
able to do that especially Europe must
think who could take over after Mr
protein with whom can we have at least
some talk they will not be democracy
like in the European Union campus at
least let's hope we can keep it but we
need some contact points in Russia
itself with whom we can build for the
future because Russia will not then
probably go away we hope Putin would go
away his his holy Gods will go away but
Russia will stay and we need people with
whom we can talk and with whom we can
renew economic relationship on an equal
basis not depending on Russian gas and
oil and giving uh
thank you I'm sorry but we are running a
little bit late
um Mr milovanov our last speaker you
connected
thank you yes
um I want to make a couple of remarks
one is about solution because in the
background discussion of what could be a
ceasefire peace solution the key here is
sustainable solution
and also I need to understand that the
temporary solution to piece is basically
means that the occupied territory
continuation of war crimes and torture
of people
sanctions the purpose of sanctioned
sanctions actually is a military tool
with the purpose to deny Russia in the
future the aggressive military
capability so the alternative to
sanctions sanctions are costly but the
alternative to sanctions the costlier so
as an economist I would say when we talk
about the cost of sanctions we should
look at the opportunity cost and the
personality cost is much higher that's
of course creates pressure political
pressure but here is where clear
leadership is needed to explain that uh
of course to support people but to
explain that the Alternatives of wars
finally on reaching out to Russians
actually there are conversations with
Russian opposition figures and many of
them are engaged in support of Ukraine
in very direct material way these
conversations are not public for obvious
reasons however I I think we should
LED Russians figure out for themselves
what they want to be and how they want
to live after this war rather than try
to create or build democracies there or
do something else to reach out to some
people and Empower some people that
hasn't worked in the past and that is
not going to work themselves again we
need a sustainable solution with Russia
and they have to have their own
Reckoning and understanding at the same
time uh I think uh we need uh to be very
very clear after the war that our job of
the entire world is to ensure that
Russia stops being aggressive military
power it's not our job to be built a
democracy there or find Partners but
rather our job is to ensure that they
don't pose a threat to neighboring
countries and don't invade in the future
thank you
thank you very much Mr miloganov I think
we all agree with that and we really
send you our best wishes stay safe and
you know that you have this house a
solidarity for your country uh thank you
to all the speakers
we finish now our public hearing on
sanctions and I really thank again all
the people who participated in the
hearing and now we have to move on to
the next point in our agenda which is
the election of the second Vice chair of
this committee you know following the
resignation on October 20th of Stephanie
young as a second Vice chair of the
committee we have to elect her successor
they substitutes taking part in the vote
are Kristoff hanseng Eva my bell Martin